comme premier dans les titres un
reportage qui fera plaisir à tous les
enfants qui nous regardent nous nous
rendons dans le village du père noël en
finlande une localité célèbre dans le
monde entier une notoriété business
david arnold laponie finlandaise
no - de la ville de rovaniemi le village
du père noël
nous sommes à 2500 km de paris en plein
sur le cercle polaire
c'est ici que travail le barbu le plus
célèbre du monde
son activité principale recevoir les
enfants et leurs familles quatre cent
mille visiteurs par an un job plutôt
lucratif pour être pris en photo avec
lui il faut débourser la modique somme
de 20 euros
aujourd'hui le père noël est riche mais
il reste célibataire je cherche une
charmante demoiselle d'environ 450 ans
mais il n'y en a pas aucune ne veut
admettre un tel âge wants to total
d'attaché sont les globes le père noël a
beau être généreux avec les enfants il
n'en perd pas moins le sens du commerce
10 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires annuel au sein du village de
nombreuses maisonnettes en bois propose
moult souvenirs du husky en peluche aux
chaussons lapon mais la maison
principale c'est la poste chaque jour 32
mille commandes parviennent au père noël
elles arrivent de tous les pays du monde
et pour recevoir une réponse du célèbre
personnage
il ya un secret une gentille lettre qui
parle de votre famille de vos loisirs et
pas juste une liste de souhaits je veux
si je veux ça et bien les pirates vous
répondre ici on peut envoyer une carte
avec le tampon officiel de la fameuse
poche ou encore pour 6 euros
remplir un formulaire afin que le père
noël et qui 20 mo à la personne de son
choix une atmosphère assez commercial
qui ne diminue en rien la fascination
des enfants
j'aimerais bien une fatigue peut tuer le
père noël existe telle légende c'est
impressionnant de voir
et à ton avis là que l'âge 700 ans le
père noël reçoit aussi les cadeaux les
tutsis lui offrent traditionnellement
leur tétine
une manière de s'en débarrasser
définitivement pour grandir un peu